♪
PETE: BORDER AGENTS INTERCEPTING
NEARLY HUNDRED MIGRANTS ILLEGALS
ON THE ARIZONA BORDER WEBS.
147 OF THEM KIDS.
THIS JUST DAYS AFTER FOX
CAPTURED THIS FOOTAGE OF NEARLY
300 MIGRANTS, ILLEGALLIES TRYING
TO PUSH THEIR WAY PAST BORDER
PATROL IN TEXAS.
FORMER ARIZONA NATIONAL GUARD
GENERAL AND ARIZONA SENATE
CANDIDATE MICHAEL MAGUIRE JOINS
US NOW TO REACT.
MICHAEL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
WE SEE THESE IMAGES.
WE SEE THESE NUMBERS.
YOU’RE RUNNING FOR OFFICE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE NOW TO DEAL WITH THIS
SITUATION?
>> GOOD MORNING, PETE.
>>
PETE: GOOD MORNING.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE RIGHT NOW
IS WE NEED TO SECURE THE BORDER.
WE NEED TO BUILD THE WALL.
PROVIDE MONEY TO SURGEON THE
GUARD TO THE BORDER.
BIDEN IS DERELICT IN HIS DUTY,
NOT DOING THAT AND YOU CAN SEE
147 OF 200 ARE NEARLY THREE TO
ONE THIS IS ORGANIZED BY THE
CARTELS.
IT’S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SAYING
FOR THE LAST FOUR MONTHS.
IT’S HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND DRUGS
AT THE SOUTHWEST BORDER.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE LESS SAFE.
BORDER SECURITY IS MUCH MORE
THAN NATIONAL SECURITY, IT’S
HUMAN SECURITY.
PETE: THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
HAVE SEEN IS NOT NOT BUILDING
THE WALL.
THEY ARE TAKING IT DOWN OR
STOPPING THE CONSTRUCTION OF IT
WHAT MORE SHOULD STATES BE
DOING?
>> WELL, WHAT WE DID HERE JUST
PRIOR TO MY RETIREMENT AS THE
COMMANDING GENERAL OF THE GUARD
WE ADDED OUR GUARDSMEN TO LOCAL
SHERIFFS TO ALLOW THEM TO
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
SOUTHERN ARIZONA IN OUR POORER
COUNTIES.
THE PROBLEM IS, PETE.
THEY CAN’T DO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT THAT’S BEEN RULED ON
FEDERAL RESPONSIBILITY AND BIDEN
IS NOT DOING IT.
PETE: BIDEN IS NOT DOING IT THE
NATIONAL GUARD CAN ASSIST BUT
NOT APPREHEND AND ULTIMATELY,
WHEN YOU SEE THIS FLOOD, WE KNOW
THE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
APPREHENDED.
HOW MUCH LARGER IS THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CROSSING IN
YOUR ESTIMATION?
WE SEE THESE MASSIVE INCREASES
IN APPREHENSIONS BUT THE
GOT-AWAYS.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT CAN I TELL YOU IS
THE NUMBER OF -- JUST IN THE
LAST CYCLE, 188,000 IN ONE MONTH
TO GIVE YOU SOME COMPARISON,
PETE, IN 2014, DURING THE MAIN
SURGE UNDER OBAMA WHEN DID HE
FUND THE GUARD, WAS 68,000.
SO NEARLY A THREE FOLD INCREASE
AND I SUSPECT THERE IS A LOT
THAT AREN’T BEING APPREHENDED
AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE CLEARLY
LESS SAFE.
WE’RE CREATING A CRISIS, AN
EMERGENCY DOWN THERE.
IF HE REVOKES TITLE 42 UNDER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH, THAT’S QUITE A
DICHOTOMY WHILE THEY ARE
INCREASING PUBLIC HEALTH
RESTRICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA, SAME
TIME.
PETE: QUITE A CONTRAST IF YOU
ARE GETTING RID OF THAT PROTOCOL
ON THE BORDER AND PUTTING KIDS
IN D.C. SCHOOLS BACK IN MASKS.
BY THE WAY NOTE TO ALL OF OUR IT
MICHAEL’S SPEECH.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE IN A RALLY
TONIGHT WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
TURNING POINT ACTION RALLY.
IT’S GOING TO STREAM LIVE
TONIGHT 6:00 P.M. EASTERN.
YOU WILL SEE BOTH GENERAL
MICHAEL MAGUIRE AND OTHERS ON
STAGE WITH TURNING POINT ACTION
AS WELL AS DONALD TRUMP LYON
THAT STAGE ONLY AT FOX NATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, GENERAL.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> YES, THANKS, PETE, AND GO TO
ELECT MIC.COM IS OUR SITE.
WE WILL BE THERE TONIGHT LOTS OF
ENERGY WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP